[Musique]
rougement c'est à quelques encablures du
site ou général de lattre de tassigny a
établi son pc donc au château de bournel
qui était la résidence de léonel de
moustier ancien député président du
conseil général du tout et qui fut un
des 80 parlementaires a refusé les
pleins pouvoirs au maréchal pétain
il est mort en déportation et donc
rougemont donc c'est un lieu symbolique
c'est un marqueur de l'histoire de la
première armée française
[Musique]
on
nous
[Musique]
ces africains il faut le dire avait déjà
beaucoup donné certains d'entre eux
avaient participé -déjà- la campagne
d'italie
ces soldats originaires d'afrique avait
du mal à supporter les rigueurs de
l'hiver de l'est de la france
effectivement donc ils sont remplacés
par des résistants qui connaissent le
terrain et qui sont rompus aux rigueurs
de l'hiver
le point final de cette épopée cc
berchtesgaden c'est le nid d'aigle du
führer est le tout dernier épisode
militaire mais qui prend un caractère
diplomatique donc c'est la présence du
général de tact de lattre de tassigny à
berlin le 8 mai 1945 lors de la
ratification de la capitulation sans
conditions de l'allemagne
donc c'est une image assez forte et qui
illustre le prestige de la première
armée française le général de gaulle
avait souhaité que la france soit
représentée par le général de lattre de
tassigny
[Musique]
une tombe militaire ne peut pas être
relevées dont un soldat
il eût mais ici à la nécropole de
rougemont où dans un carré militaire
eh bien il est là pour l'éternité et ça
c'est l'illustration d'un principe c'est
la reconnaissance la reconnaissance que
la nation se doit d'avoir envers ceux
qui sont tombés pour elle
[Musique]